we start with this question of how much
money has gone into Bitcoin okay so how
much money has alright when you put
money into a private company like an
angel investment where does the money go
goes onto the balance sheet of the
company right how much money has gone in
the Bitcoin everybody keeps talking
about how much money has gone in the
Bitcoin how much money has gone in the
Bitcoin right now or more importantly
where does it go okay billions right
in reality money doesn't go in the big
coin remember when you are selling
something directly like when you when
somebody sells your private company
stock that money goes in their balance
sheet let's go so if you put them put a
million dollars in the value of the
company it's probably not gonna be less
than a billion because there's a billion
on the balance sheet there's not two
cash in there your cash goes there when
you buy a Bitcoin it doesn't go in the
Bitcoin it goes to the person that just
bought it from you so that's very
different than putting something
directly in it's basically a transaction
side to side you know your million went
to their million their Bitcoin came to
you and then the system Bitcoin system
still has no cash so there's nothing to
catch it as it starts to fall so as it
goes from valuation of you know 1
million to 240 billion right now it's
all mark-to-market expansion of balance
sheet now essentially we're signing
value to that and we're saying it's
worth as much but if people decide it's
not worth that much it's not like
there's a hundred billion a bag that'll
stop it from collapsing